comme mentale les goûts l'usp est écouté
aujourd'hui on va parler des live vous
suivez un peu des live ou pas c'est
vraiment en train de rentrer fort dans
la culture la joie mon père m'en a parlé
c'est marrant j'ai vraiment ça en
référence quand mes parents il me parle
d'un truc je me dis ouah ça y est ça a
franchi la limite du grand public tout
le monde connaît maintenant tout le
monde est au courant même mes parents
qui sont pas du tout de cette génération
là c'est incroyable on perd le jour il
va me parler de la crypto monnaie je
vais m'évanouir
on a fait jouer à très longtemps regardé
un peu d fail qui a eu en plein live
aujourd'hui c'est sam ya pas que des
fêtes c'est juste des trucs mignon
amusant au cool qui sont passés en live
parce que le format du lab ce qui est
drôle c'est qu'il ya énormément
d'imprévus et surtout ces imprévus tu
peux pas les cacher puisque ça s'est
passé en live voilà comme moi à tokyo la
3 heures du mat quand je découvris j'ai
acheté un kebab tu assumes deal with it
et c'est tout j'adore exemple ici on a
un streamer qui fait un cache cache à
ikea déjà ça me fait rire céder à des
entreprises qui vont des meubles et qui
ont pas anticiper le flot number one de
leurs magasins les gens qui font des
cache cache à ces terribles ils vont se
retrouver à devoir mettre des pics dans
les dressings et tout pour pas que les
gens puissent s'y cacher c'est triste
alors oui oui au programme c'est gonflé
vous les gars je suis content d'arriver
cette vidéo parce que on était des
millions ici à ne pas suspecter que des
gens puissent être cachés dans des
dressings quand on ouvre la porte les
gars allaient faire des cache cache
au nom des bic est assez vrai que c'est
drôle je vais lancer un truc ikea je
suis pas responsable disclaimer voilà
les mentions légales de ma vidéo ikea je
ne suis pas responsable si les gens
s'amusent dans vos magasins à faire des
cache cache ne m'attaque est pas en
justice sponsorisé mois plus tôt ok ça
les gars ça les gars ça me rend ouf lui
c'est tyler one c'est un streamer
spécialisée dans la musculation pas du
tout il joue à league of legend c'est
bon alors pourquoi at il ce corps il a
la particularité d'être extrêmement
stocks
à tel point que il te fait des soulevé
de terre mon frérot cd soulevé de
planètes qui te fait d'accord déjà sont
survoltés avec le move qu' il ya des
commentateurs je n'ai même pas qu'il y
avait des commentateurs de soulever de
terre c'est incroyable tu veux dire quoi
par la baraque et exxon
la barre est de retour
[Musique]
c'est tellement une autre culture
après je vais vous dire le secret il
joua lol vous rendez compte le niveau de
haine et de frustration qu'il faut avoir
pour être capable d'un coup de se lâcher
de soulever en tout point y'a que les
joueurs de l'oflc en sont capables
sachez tout de même pour ceux qui
n'avaient pas vu que on a fait avec
locklear une séance de sport en live on
n'avait pas trop communiquer dessus
parce qu'on voulait pas faire complexer
tout le game des streamer youtuber et
tout mais laissez moi vous dire que
cette séance elle est témoin ou au non
c'est trop mignon c'est un jeune qui a
laissé tourner son stream est sa mère
elle est venu s'adresser aux viewer du
jeune c'est trop mignon non mais là
vraiment vous rendez compte
j'aimerais pas que ça m'arrive ce n'est
que le jour où château avec ma mère
vient s'asseoir ici pour vous dire merci
vraiment pour les cas il est très
heureux
le dossier je vais angoissé toute la
journée d'hier pensons aux merde mais
lui dans son cas c'est adorable ce trou
là ça devient peut arrêter c'était
mignon début là c'est dommage qu'est ce
que c'est que ça arrêtez vous voulez
juste gratté des abonnés les garder ça
se boit je veux dire il à deux doigts de
se tiennent pour le kart avec son @ but
qui veux-tu berné jeunes enfants mega
d'ailleurs sur les leviers règne à débat
imaginez quand il y aura la 5g et où
tout le monde va live irl très souvent
ça veut dire que quand tu sortiras dans
la rue il ya de grandes chances pour qu
à un moment donné tu te retrouves en
live sur internet sur la chaîne de
quelqu'un à ton insu
c'est un peu bas dost round suivant ah
ça c'est ma passion c'est les petits
streamer qui se fondent à rodez
ils s'en lavent ils font du bruit ou je
sais pas quoi et à quelqu'un qu'on vous
l'apporté qui les roustes qu'est ce
qu'il fait ce streamer ses dépôts mais
il se passe quoi là ils se changent
j'aimerais que tu arrêtes ça cela tu
fais du bruit tu nous dérange
en plus je trouve que tu as l'air
vachement idiot quand tu fais ça le
proviseur m'a appelé pour me dire qu'il
ne croyait pas du tout en toi et anton
potentiel tu es misérable franchement
lui l'algérie sont davantage il reste
impassible
il râle pas il admet ses torts il essaie
d'être expéditif mais elle est
surenchérit encore et encore à tel point
qu'à un moment il obligé de lâcher le
morceau il lui dire sur la nomination au
nom alors ça c'est trop mignon il ya un
truc impitoyable avec les live c'est que
c'est très dur quand tu commences à
l'arrivée d'attirer des gens sûreté live
le phénomène du monde qui attire le
monde sur les lie ville et décuplé et là
c'est un streamer qui parle de
mathématiques et mes gars passionné et
tout et c'est la première fois en des
dizaines d'heures de live qu'il a un
viewer son premier viewer news juste
mais madame non
bref c'est trop mignon jeu j'étais à 15
secondes de la fin j'assume pas plus
humain il s'est déboîté l'épaule
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce live aussi là il fait une
dégustation de tout ce qui est à la
caisse à carrefour où c'est comment là
je ne comprends pas comment il se doit
de les paul est excusez moi non
c'est pour ça que je danse pas les gars
c'est pas que je sais pas danser
t'imagines le truc juste c'est dangereux
mais trop ça ça les gars peut-être vbc
dans votre estime ou peut-être c'est
vous qui allez montez dans mon estime si
ça vous fait marrer bordel au seulement
drôle le gars c'est tellement la blague
que tu fais quand tu assumes patron 1p
mais tu le fais en blague
oui tu es là dix premiers tu sais très
bien ce que ces frais ont tu as de l'air
chaud sous les fesses au moment où on se
parle
fais nous un petit au pain et c'est bon
c'est derrière nous ok ça le combo vous
allez chialer c'est une strie meuse qui
a plus de 65 ans us et ça fait des
années qu'elle joue à minecraft et
qu'elle fait un monde
regardez
[Musique]
elle est toute contente elle est trop
fier oh là là ça va sous terre et tout
dans mes rendez vous il est un coin
penser que notre génération sera ce
genre de soixantenaires est-ce que la
phase forward up quarante ans plus tard
vous ouvrez youtube et twitch et on est
toujours là à faire des vidéos des lives
on a juste des rides on est tous
contents mais on se fait des optiques il
faut continuer à l'arrivée entre nous tu
as j'ai trop hâte de voir ça haha ça ça
tue charles leclerc pilote de f1 il est
en plein live tweet et là il ya un soap
donc ils remercient le sobre et le solde
s'appelle charlotte signer charlotte
signer c'est la copine de charles
leclerc
du coup lui naturellement la facture le
6 mai leur rôle ou ses moyens comme l'a
[Rires]
trop mal
si vous n'arrivez pas à joindre un ami à
vous qui est streamer laissé un message
en vous abonnant à son switch c'est 100%
écuries
suis-je en train de dire ça pour voler
cinq euros à tous mes amis évidemment
c'est pas juste et setting obs qui
peuvent ruiner ton live ob à ses
logiciels qu'on utilise pour streamé
[Musique]
watts
ouais mec en même temps même si je puis
me permettre
tu l'as bien rentabiliser un ton
étagères à ya plus un millimètre carré
de dispo là je vais dire une phrase
juste pour faire kiffer le bricoleur il
avait des chevilles ou pas dans son mur
les gars j'ai découvert l'existence de
la cheville et il est vrai c'est game
center et c'est ce qui fait que ce
miroir qui vous angoisse temps depuis
qu'on a fait le nouveau bureau avec
lorraine n'est toujours pas tombé la
chemise hawaïenne live activités
manuelles on en a fait on a fait un
gameplay en live je vais pas fini mais
tout s'est bien passé
lui c'est quoi c'est comme si c'était un
gros cube en lego a mais ces gens un
gros rubik's cube cas ça a l'air très
long oman no
adieu c'est top c'est ce qui s'est passé
ça va péter fort moyenne gamme pour son
chien ça tu essaies arrêté encore une
fois j'en ai ma dans toutes les vidéos
en ce moment il ya un truc un streamer
s'est endormi à son réveil il commet le
clutch
non mais attends mais on est où là mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça ah qu'est le
montrent en train de jouer à cs et tu
t'endors comme ça mes mecs c'est ta
chaise de bureau dont il donc là il se
réveille et va clutch c'est à dire il va
faire gagner le round à son équipe
[Musique]
[Rires]
comment c'est possible ça moi je
m'endors pas sur ma chaise j'ai jamais
faire une clutch ça me saoule c'est ça
le secret messieurs dames c'est la fin
de cette vidéo vous l'avez vous
appréciez - oui j'adore cette ère du
live je trouve ça génial
moi je me vais vraiment regarder de plus
en plus alors c'est en fait je me suis
habitué à l'ambiance un peu reposante
cas sur l'élève ya pas de queue d'action
des effets de montage c'est très jean
smooth naturel ça se consomme très
différemment des vidéos je consomme
toujours pas mal de vidéos mais j'avoue
que j'ai en ce moment je découvre des
trucs en live parce qu il se passe trop
de choses quoi en live c'est n'importe
quoi
allez prenez soin de vous et à très vite
dans une prochaine vidéo plein de bisous
les sens
[Musique]
oh